the idea of an experience it validates
what you do I mean I think that happens
for me every time I ride the motorcycle
I got introduced really to God and his
is you know his taste of machines that
he makes and I asked God if you wanted
to start a motorcycle business and what
did I say
he said no yeah so I was like okay well
the reason that we should do this is
because the machine is amazing and we're
gonna die and then eventually well you
said yeah I couldn't argue with that one
yeah
took three years to go from prototype to
the first model the coyote t1 and we've
been selling for about a year now
our motorcycle has a lot of components
that are made you know with high-end
technology and machinery but at the same
time but it's also you know these
beautiful welds that are done by hand
the first time we really got to get it
outside of testing garden I went for a
ride and it was an amazing experience
just to be riding those bikes two lanes
you know 100 miles an hour
I'm sorry 55 miles an hour
it's our cut of our home ride Santa
Monica Mountains Pacific Coast Highway
you know this bike was born in breads
it has to make you giggle you ride
yeah
just feeling that that it worked you
know and also just looking over you and
just like doing better you can take a
[ __ ] I would like to in having that
swing Wow god it's a beautiful machine
buddy back
you